the most successful entrepreneurs that
I've encountered are a lot like Yeti
mugs and hear me out so you know there's
mugs that in the middle they can stay
hot or they can stay cold independent of
the external surroundings entrepreneurs
that are really successful have to do
that too because at every level of
Entrepreneurship there's more and more
noise can you imagine the amount of
lawsuits that are ongoing in a billion
dollar company it's all day long every
day and so most people spend all of
their effort trying to fix their
surroundings because they think that if
they fix and they control everything
around them they'll feel a certain way
when in my experience it's been the
reverse if I can fix how I feel none of
these things I label as good or bad
anymore and so then I can walk through
them through the fire without having to
get burned